et vladimir poutine doit s'entretenir
demain avec emmanuel macron le président
français qui va échanger également tout
à l'heure avec son homologue ukrainien
volodimir zielinski les tractations
diplomatiques continuent également en
allemagne se tient ce week-end la
conférence annuelle sur la sécurité à
munich où sont attendus les ministres
des affaires étrangères du g 7 ainsi que
la vice-présidente américaine kamala
harris le président des états unis joe
biden s'est lui exprimé hier soir pour
la deuxième fois en une semaine alors
que les chefs des diplomaties américaine
et russe doivent se rencontrer à nouveau
jeudi la correspondance à washington de
thomas boleyn
la principale évolution dans le discours
de joe biden se rend jeudi soir c'est
qu'il dit désormais être convaincu que
vladimir poutine a pris une décision et
que cette décision est de lancer une
offensive en ukraine le président
américain qui a une nouvelle fois rejeté
les affirmations russe sur des
provocations ukrainienne écoutez le
nous continuons de voir de plus en plus
de désinformation jeux destinés à une
audience russe comme les déclarations
des séparatistes qui affirme que
l'ukraine planifié une attaque massive
dans le donbass écoutez il n'y a
absolument rien qui laisserait penser
cela serait même contre toute logique de
penser que les ukrainiens choisirait ce
moment alors que plus de cent cinquante
mille militaires sont positionnés sur
leurs frontières pour aggraver un
conflit vieux de plusieurs années
le locataire de la maison blanche qui
continuent de penser qu'une attaque va
survenir dans les tout prochains jours
nous continuerons de soutenir l'ukraine
matériellement et financièrement il a
aussi expliqué que les états unis à
défendre et chaque centimètre des pays
membres de l'otan et malgré tout joe
biden dit encore voir de la place pour
la diplomatie écouter
la russie peut toujours choisir la
diplomatie ce n'est pas trop tard pour
une désescalade
et pour retourner à la table des
négociations
la russie a accepté une rencontre entre
le secrétaire d'état anthony blinken et
le ministre des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov
le 24 février en europe
mais si la russie s'engagent
militairement avant cette rencontre il
sera clair qu'ils ont tourné
définitivement le dos à la diplomatie
ils auront choisi la guerre
on rappelle que cette allocution de joe
biden la deuxième en moins d'une semaine
sur le dossier ukrainien est intervenue
après un entretien en visioconférence
organisée ce vendredi entre le président
américain et des pays alliés tels que le
canada la france l'allemagne ou encore
le royaume-uni et puis un peu plus tôt
dans la journée ce vendredi il y avait
le traditionnel point presse à la maison
blanche avec deux responsables
américains qui se sont exprimé à la
tribune le responsable des cyberattaques
qui affirme que la russie est
responsable des cyber attaques survenues
cette semaine en ukraine et puis un
responsable américain en charge de
l'économie internationale qui explique
qu'en cas d'invasion l'a réussie sera
isolé des marchés financiers deviendra
je cite un paria pour la communauté
internationale